hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is the newest flagship smartphone
from LG now technically this did come
out in October and I wish I could have
done this video a little earlier but
better late than never right so this is
five facts about the LG v10 so number
one is this is Loki one of the most
underrated smartphones of this year 2015
I don't know what it is about a lot of
the randoms I'm seeing of like the best
smartphones of the year will inevitably
have a whole lot of Samsung pull out of
Apple and deservingly so and then legend
low to roll a throne in there of course
Huawei gets in there with the Nexus 6p
but for whatever reason LG gets left off
the list a lot even though their two
best phones ever have come out this year
the LG g4 and then this what I think is
a slightly improved version of the g4 in
this v10 so it's an all-around high-end
flagship of course but with a few key
improvements beyond just the specs over
that g4 so this is one made it worth
another release and it was kind of weird
to see an improved version of what was
already LG's best phone go under the
radar but it has hopefully this video
can change that number two is one of the
most unique features of this phone even
though it might not immediately be
noticeable when you're looking at it is
up front up here on the top it's the
second display it's up at the top right
corner up in the bezel it's a little
easier to see on the white version since
it's hidden up there in the bezel but
it's a 160 by 10 40 second screen on top
of the primary quad HD display and it
has its own function first of all it's
always on even when the main display is
off it's showing your date time and
battery and while it's off you can swipe
over to get some quick shortcuts which
are handy and then the main display one
that's on you can show a bunch of stuff
on the secondary you get notifications
when you get new ones
you also have apps shortcuts of your
choice you can have your five most
recent apps you can get media controls
and even a custom signature message some
of this stuff is gimmicky and some of it
is actually kind of useful I think it's
most useful when showing new
notifications since that's actually
saving real space on the main display
but it can kind of be a bit of a
struggle on such a big phone to reach up
at the top with one hand to say tap an
app shortcut I think most people would
just multitask the normal way but it is
interesting ever tha less and
implemented pretty well alright number
is that this phone is a rare breed a
flagship Android smartphone with a
removable back a replaceable battery and
expandable storage I say it's a rare
breed because if you look through the
smartphones released in the last year or
two removable backs have become less and
less common in the name of build quality
most smartphone bodies have sealed end
backs but some still toss in a microSD
card slot for expandable storage LG v10
does that card slot and a fully
removable 3000 milliamp hour battery
that is technically the fastest charging
you can have available in a smartphone
now this phone actually does have quick
charging built in and it also has a
pretty good battery life already
averaging me just shy of like 4 hours of
screen on time but if I ever get low all
I have to do is have another battery in
my back pocket switch it out 0% to 100%
in 15 seconds not a lot of phones can do
that anymore right so number 4 this is
the world's first smartphone camera with
manual mode in video and that's part of
an overall larger focus on the camera
it's one of the biggest improvements
from the g4 pretty much everything about
this cameras really good it's an
improved 16 megapixel shooter with
optical image stabilization so pretty
much no cons on paper and the
ridiculously awesome camera app so you
can see it uses the second screen to
hold the toggles between the different
modes that's useful so simple mode is
the easiest it's literally just point
and shoot tap anywhere on the viewfinder
to take a picture that's it
right then auto mode is what you're sort
of used to in a smartphone you tap to
focus and expose and you have your
normal shutter button flash and settings
etc all that stuff is there then manual
mode is a sort of a pro mode that we're
seeing a bunch of smartphones now and
this manual mode is awesome
you get precise white balance control a
manual focus distance slider ISO even a
shutter speed slider so you can set your
starter speed anywhere from 30 seconds
all the way up to one six thousandth of
a second so this is ideal for action
shots and fast moving objects and
guaranteeing that nothing will be blurry
so the camera has no problem cranking up
the ISO so manual mode is great and then
there's manual video mode which is dope
again white balance control manual focus
ISO shutter speed and then there's even
a fine-tuned audio control so you can
choose whether to favor the front-facing
or back facing microphone
and it just might gain and everything
like that this is like a full-fledged
pro video camera in a smartphone's body
and both the photos and videos that come
from the smartphone are some of the
sharpest most detailed best-looking
images I've seen come out of a
smartphone this year which is awesome oh
and as a bonus this thing also has two
front facing five megapixel cameras one
for normal portraits and another right
next to it for a wide-angle for those
super important group selfies bottom
line if you're looking for a quality
camera in a smartphone you need to be
looking at this v10 okay so number five
is despite all that praise this phone is
not perfect now I mentioned at the
beginning of the video like this is one
of the better phones of the year and it
definitely is underrated but it's not
for everyone right so first of all it's
a really big phone as most 5.7 inch
phones are you know big metal rails on
the side pretty thick and then the hard
to reach second screen it's not really a
one-handed phone for most people and in
my personal opinion it's not the
prettiest either it does have a new
fingerprint reader on the back power
button which is new from the g4 but it
struggles with accuracy sometimes and it
is definitely a step below the likes of
the Nexus 6p and 5x and iPhone 6s in
terms of speed and convenience that way
and the speaker is another weakness it's
just that tiny grille at the bottom
super easy to block accidentally and it
does distort that high volume and some
may or may not like this LG skin on top
of Android which is still 5.1 by the way
still looking for that marshmallow
update so there's a lot going on with
this phone you can't overlook that it's
a great overall device you know
multitasker a smooth performer etc but
it's also one of the most unique phones
out there so hopefully this video helps
you get a good idea of that anyway
that's been it hope you enjoyed this
quick look I decided to do this review a
little bit differently than most but
hopefully it's in time for the holiday
season for you to get an idea because
this phone is definitely worth a look
anyway thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
you